Rusia Ucrania Turquía y Naciones Unidas
han conseguido a prorrogar el acuerdo
por las exportaciones de trigo cereal y
grano ucraniano que fue aprobado el mes
de julio pasado en Estambul a través de
la mediación de Turquía y de Naciones
Unidas este acuerdo tenía que caducar el
próximo sábado 19 de noviembre sino
todas las partes aceptaban su renovación
Rusia había estado
amenazando con romper este acuerdo
porque según Moscú ella quiere ayudar y
quiere asegurarse de que sus
exportaciones propias de cereal y de
fertilizantes serán permitidas en un
futuro hacia países europeos
occidentales hasta la fecha no lo son
por culpa del temor de muchas empresas
occidentales a recibir sanciones
secundarias por comercializar con
empresas a rusas Ucrania quería que este
acuerdo fuese renovado no por 120 días
como la ha acabado siendo sino por un
año sin embargo no ha sido así a pesar
por culpa de Rusia que ha querido
asegurarse que tendrá este poder de Beto
de nuevo dentro de 120 días a finales
de invierno del año que viene y hay
inicios de primavera según ha asegurado
el secretario general de Naciones Unidas
Antonio Gutiérrez esta renovación es un
éxito de la eplomacia internacional y
sobre todo de los fuerzas de mediación
tanto de Naciones Unidas como de
Estambul y de Turquía que es donde está
el centro de coordinación conjunto en el
que hay a inspectores y asesores rusos
ucranes que conjuntamente siguen
investigando y siguen inspeccionando los
barcos que seguirán saliendo Durante los
próximos 120 días desde los puertos
ucranianos